Like green arrow no not like green arrow that dude
goes with brony conventions dressed in the back
half of twilight sparkle with a four inch wide
butthole drilled in the costume no i actually
heard that's true about green arrow but that's
the first thing he said that's real and aquaman
fish well yeah obviously
Welcome back everyone
this will be my full dc peacemaker episode 8
finale video there were so many big easter eggs
big cameo scenes we have to talk about too big
surprises so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they also just
confirmed the show has been renewed for season two
so of course i'll do videos for season two when
they start dropping footage and big details about
what's happening careful for spoilers if you have
not watched the episode yet but just starting with
the big stuff first obviously everyone's gonna be
talking about the giant justice league cameo scene
minus batman and cyborg i'm so sick of that rumor
it's not a rumor berry but it was actually jason
mamoa legit and ezra miller who came back to pay
off the joke about him having sex with fish
with ezra miller's flash just doubling down
on the burn like wait a minute i thought that it
was true i'm assuming that henry cavill superman
here and galkadot's wonder woman were just full cg
characters like henry cavill himself didn't come
back to film this scene and gal gadot didn't
actually come back as wonder woman that's why
their characters are kind of covered in shadow
like you don't fully see their faces the way you
see aquaman's face in the flash's face james gunn
said that the episode would tease some upcoming
big movies that would cross over with the movies
this is what he was talking about because both the
flash movie and aquaman 2 are coming out later
this year within a couple months of each other
ben affleck's batman is coming back during the
flash movie as well but i assume that there's
just rules about having batman on tv that they're
really hardcore about like okay we'll give you
most of the justice league but you can't have
batman the batman movie with robert pattinson
coming out in a couple weeks probably also has
something to do with that too like okay we have
enough batman going around we don't need to have
even more batman on the tv show either way it
was super cool it was a huge surprise i was not
expecting this i was expecting something smaller
like a small green lantern reference or cameo
scene but the actual title of the episode is it's
cow or never a reference to the butterflies alien
cow that they're trying to kill and the phrase
it's now or never because if they don't kill
it now the butterflies will finish teleporting
it to their other secret base and finish taking
over the world the opening scene just picks up
right where they left off in last week's episode
with the cliffhanger leota trying to apologize to
the peacemaker but he and vigilante just making
all those fart noises because he's still pissed
off at her till the end of the episode after she
saves the day with a little bit of teamwork and
a little bit of human torpedo helmet he explains
his special vow to only kill people in the name of
peace saying that he took the vow because of his
brother keith's death he made a vow so that no one
would die for no reason which is messed up for all
kinds of reasons as leota kind of sarcastically
throws at him it's not really possible for
peacemaker himself to stop all death from being
meaningless but the idea is that peacemaker's been
using the vow is more of like an emotional crutch
for the past 20 years or so however long it's
been that he's been killing people on the regular
it was his way of dealing or not dealing with the
trauma although to be fair he did finally stand up
to his father white dragon so he's starting to
deal with his trauma but the whole bit with him
hallucinating white dragon is just a way to show
you that he's got a lot of therapy work ahead of
him it's gonna be a long time before he completely
deals with all of his metaphorical demons
and they do clarify during the episode it's not
a butterfly trick or anything like he's not on
drugs or anything even though he does do a lot
of drugs it's just a manifestation of his own
personal trauma coming through his subconscious
he's literally just yelling at himself here
it's also a really clever way for them to bring
robert patrick back in season two even though
they kill the character off have white dragon
continue yelling crazy stuff at him all the time
vigilante reveals that eagerly is his second best
friend after peacemaker then leota name drops the
justice league to her mother amanda waller setting
up their big cameo scene asking her to call them
in because the butterflies are too big of a threat
for their small team to handle and because they do
show up at the end of the episode even though it
sounds like amanda waller was yelling at her on
the other side of the phone like just continue
with the mission it does confirm that amanda
waller did in fact call in the justice league
you're late you the butterflies reveal that the
cow is female and it is a holy cow like holy cow
the phrase and they confirm the other secret base
that they're teleporting it to is in maine on the
eastern seaboard of the united states they bring
back all of peacemaker's weird funny helmets
and pay off a whole bunch of jokes there's an
underwater world one that just allows you to
breathe underwater they bring back the scabies
helmet joke he calls it scabies for all saying
that everyone in a one mile radius will get it
except for the wear this is actually a big change
from that post credit scene with the helmet too
earlier in the season during that scene his father
actually told him that it only gave the where
scabies and that he created it because everyone
should have scabies at least once in their life
all the post credit scenes are mostly just
outtakes and bloopers though so you have to
consider them kind of like deleted scenes there's
an anti-gravity helmet and completely unironically
this isn't a joke peacemaker says that he uses a
tiny hand fan to push himself around in the air
they bring back the sonic boom helmet from
episode 1 the one he used on the female
butterfly that he hooked up with and there's a
human torpedo helmet which they obviously used
at the end of the episode to kill the cow saying
that it literally turns you into human missile
which they pay off at the end of the episode also
the joke being that because it's a prototype it
doesn't give you any type of personal shielding
or reinforcement it just shatters every bone in
your body upon impact depending on what you use
it for and then peacemaker has the most wicked
of green arrow burns remember this is the dc eu
too so when he's joking about green arrow he's
confirming that there is an oliver queen green
arrow in the dc eu no idea who'd be playing him
you could post all your theories about that but
basically he's saying the dceu green arrow is a
brony who's secretly a full-on furry who goes
to brony conventions dressed as one of the my
little pony characters in full cosplay with an
extra-large butthole in the costume for exactly
the reason that you think someone would do that
in economos corroborates it he's like yeah i heard
that that's true green arrow definitely does that
he also confirms peacemaker was not lying about
aquaman having sex with fish now obviously they
played for a big joke at the end of the episode
when the justice league characters actually show
up and aquaman's like i hate that rumor so you can
also decide if peacemaker is also incorrect about
what was happening with green arrow maybe we'll
see a version of green arrow show up when they
do more black canary projects because i believe
they're bringing dceu black canary back either
in the bat girl movie or for her own project on
hbo max we'll see they have this big eagley joke
about him being super smart secretly but then just
playing it for a funny moment like for hot
second you think eagerly is a genius but then
like nope nope he's just a regular eagle after
he hallucinates his father for the first time
just sort of setting up the scene at the end of
the episode he reaffirms his pledge at the end of
last week's episode after he killed his father
that even though he wasn't gonna kill innocent
people anymore he had no trouble killing the
butterflies or like really really terrible people
which is why he looks so sure of himself when he
kills the butterfly guards and they have the most
heinous of crappy pants jokes now you want me
to risk my life while wearing diarrhea pants
hey nobody said anything about diarrhea i said
oh was it diarrhea yes it was when peacemaker
says he washed the guard's clothes for economos
because he crapped his pants when he died that
is an actual thing in real life people do void
their bowels when they die so just be prepared
for that when you die someday everyone finds
your body your family you will probably just have
crapped your pants just something to look forward
to we get a much better look at the full cow and
they drop another godzilla toho monsterverse kaiju
reference when economo says that it's like a giant
caterpillar paying off the big joke about mothra
at the beginning of the series in episode one
project butterfly are we fighting a giant mothra
this time because we fought a giant starfish in
project starfish turns out peacemaker was right
on the money they also pay off the joke about
him dying his beard the peacemaker has been
yelling about all season and turns into this
big sob story sad confession about how sad his
life has been and he's never had a girlfriend
they really want you to feel bad for economos
after they use the sonic boom helmet a bunch
of times they whip out peacemaker's shield from
all the trailers it's got a giant dove of peace
on it he's all about the branding he also puts
another dove of peace on one of his guns before
they roll out but james gunn and john cena said
that they designed the peacemaker character to be
like douchey captain america and captain america
uses a shield they give the whole team a bunch
of sick takedowns while they're playing the theme
music from the intro scene do you really want to
taste it but then everybody has their own version
of like a rug pull scene where even though they do
get a bunch of takedowns they themselves all get
taken down in really crazy ways like peacemaker
crashes through pretty much every single level of
the staircase down to the bottom all the scenes
of the team here going down are just meant to
reinforce the idea that they're a ragtag group
of a-holes without any superpowers who stumble
their way through saving the world that's why
they referenced the justice league earlier in the
episode and then have the cameo scene at the end
just showing you what it would be like if regular
people without superpowers try to pull something
like this off like they would all really get hurt
that's why they all wind up in the hospital at the
end as opposed to the justice league characters
who would just shrug something like this off
the butterfly queen winds up saving peacemaker and
even though they fight a little bit she tries to
win him over by explaining the truth of their plan
also confirming why judo master was working for
them because she won him over with the truth the
flamin hot cheetos had nothing to do with it the
cheetos weren't some kind of countermeasure for
the butterflies they didn't try to turn him into
a butterfly because he was working for them and
he was just eating the flamin hot cheetos because
he liked them and because in real life james gunn
just likes them maybe there was a little product
placement there too but they also do bring back
the flamin hot cheetos joke at the end of the
episode when they're giving everybody their tag
scene and you see him crying after he sees what's
happened to all the butterflies the actual truth
of the butterflies that the queen explains to him
is that they came to earth because their planet
had become unlivable as a result of her people's
own mistakes and they took a vow like peacemaker's
vow to never let something like that happen again
so when they came to earth and saw that humans
were slowly destroying themselves destroying the
earth just like the butterflies had done to their
own planet they decided to change their plan and
take over the planet in order to save the human
race her appeal to peacemaker is also meant to
be a parallel for this scene with rick flagging
the suicide squad when rick flagg is trying to
get peacemaker to do the right thing the moral
choice and just like he did during the suicide
squad movie he seemingly chooses the mission over
the common good depending on what you think the
moral choice is here like what is the actual
right choice it's meant to be a very gray area
like there's no right or wrong answer but even
though he does kill the butterfly sentencing the
butterflies who are still alive around the world
to death the reason why this isn't a backtrack
on his character development to become a better
person is because of the reason why he chose the
mission over what might have been the moral choice
depending on how you look at it he says he wasn't
actually choosing the mission over the common good
he was actually choosing his new friends the team
saying that he killed the cow to protect the team
because he knew that if he helped the butterflies
amanda waller would just kill the whole team
detonating all the bombs in their heads it's
meant to be another parallel for the ending of
the suicide squad movie so r.i.p butterfly kaiju
cow the cows did nothing wrong she was a good
girl he kills the lock butterfly but saves the
butterfly queen or spares her she shows up at his
house at the end of the episode so it's implied
that either collected her at some point while they
were leaving or she just traveled to his home he
pours a little honey for her to eat so either he
has more stash where that came from like there is
other existing supply of honey around the world
that they could probably use to keep her alive
maybe they'll bring her back during season two as
part of the team but then they actually pay off
their huge justice league cameo scene and i love
the way the peacemaker just blows right past him
like you're late like i said i think it was only
jason mamow and ezra miller who came back to put
the costumes on and film this scene is aquaman
in the flash just to pay off the joke about him
doing it with fish in superman and wonder woman
we're just computer generated james gunn also
said there's like 30 minutes of deleted scenes
of this justice league scene with alternate takes
of ezra miller and jason momoa just yelling
funny things at each other as they walk off
maybe they'll release them at some point i haven't
seen them anywhere online yet just to explain the
timeline here too this is taking place after
the events of the suicide squad movie obviously
which itself took place after the events of the
justice league snyder cut but it's happening
before the events of the flash movie in aquaman
2. that's why ezra miller is still wearing his old
flash costume and jason momoa is still wearing the
old aquaman costume from the first aquaman movie
this is probably the only f-bombs that you'll
hear the justice league themselves drop for a
long long time ben affleck did drop two f-bombs i
think during the justice league snyder cut so this
would tie the record then i love this small detail
here too zoom and enhance so even though they've
gone to the hospital to get everyone treatment
you can see that on the way they stopped to
get food and big gulps at the convenience store
like everybody's dying we need to get everybody
treatment fast but we're kind of hungry so let's
get some junk food first peacemaker then names
leota his new second best friend after eagley
please nobody tell vigilante and leota holds
a big press conference to reveal all of amanda
waller's secrets about the suicide squad task
force x the fake diary project butterfly pretty
much everything that amanda waller has been doing
there's a big easter egg here with the news truck
it says charlton channel 5 news it's an easter egg
for the original charlton comics where peacemaker
came from and the fightin 5 team which debuted in
peacemaker number 5. because this team now is kind
of like a version of the fight and five there are
literally five of them on the team and this will
be the team in season two at least at the start
i'm assuming they'd pick up another member or
two but they bring back amanda waller for a
cameo scene to react to the news like oh hell no
it's very similar to the way she ended the first
suicide squad movie reacting to the suicide squad
turning on her like bloodsport turning on her with
the information it is also meant to dovetail
with peacemaker's character arc leota standing
up to her mother the same way that he stood up to
his father even though this is only the beginning
like this is not the end by any means this will
spill into season 2 and beyond there will be huge
ramifications for what leota just did economos
does go back to his sad little desk at bell rev
pulling out a framed version of the picture of
them jamming out to the hanoi rock's 11th street
kids song peacemaker and vigilante go back to
their fun times playing with weapons testing
out that same homemade bomb that he created
earlier in the series from the giant tank shell
the butterfly queen returns to peacemaker
implying that she'll maybe be alive during
season two assuming that they find some more honey
out there somewhere i'm sure there's more supply
that they could find around the world to keep
her alive he hallucinates his father again who
just kind of smiles at him just implying that he's
gonna continue hallucinating him into season two
in the final post-credits scene it's just a
longer version of outtakes of vigilante just
not understanding sarcasm but just some early
season two predictions the team will continue
as it is here harcourt's still gonna be the
leader there'll be some new threat that they
have to deal with some new villain group but they
won't have amanda wallers backing as much or as
many resources because amanda waller is going to
be under investigation after what leota did outing
the whole program james gunn also confirmed my
theory that they would explain what's going on
with peacemaker's father's folding space armory
that pocket dimension that he has what's going on
with all the weapons and how he created all that
stuff where he got it from in the first place
that'll be a big thing in season two james gunn
also revealed that he has a totally separate
second suicide squad spin-off tv series with
a different character that he's working on but
he didn't say which character is for so you can
post all your theories about that in the comments
if you spotted any of the big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't talk about during the video
just write them below in the comments the next
big series that i'll be doing episode videos
for will be for marvel's moon knight series also
probably do some halo episode videos too because
that'll be airing around the same time that moon
night episodes start i will be doing videos for
the batman movie soon i'm going to be posting my
review video as soon as the embargo is up i think
that's going to be at the end of the month so be
sure to go see the batman movie as soon as you can
and congratulations preston watton you're the
giveaway winner for those knives that i was
giving away in my last episode video please
email me on the about page of my channel
on desktop so i can get your contact
info and i can get those sent to you
everyone click here for my full doctor
strange multiverse of madness trailer
video from the super bowl and click here
for my moon knight super bowl trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!